As I’m sure you’re aware I’ve just hit
the big one million subscribers!
I can’t believe I’m actually here, it’s
been an amazing journey that I’ll never
forget.
A few weeks ago I asked you on Facebook to
ask me questions about myself.
So here’s another Q&A to celebrate this
gargantuan milestone.
Mark asked, “What was your favourite video
out of all the ones you’ve made.”
I’ve enjoyed making every video, it’s
amazing how interesting even the most mundane
of topics can be once you learn a bit about
it.
But my favourite was “Can You Live Forever?”,
I found researching it absolutely fascinating.
When it comes to technology we live in a very
prosperous time.
There’s so many mind-blowing studies going
on, seeing how far we can push the human body
and reading about them really interested me.
Jack, Harshit, Nupur, Jordan, Cedar and Alex
asked “How long does it take you to make
a video?”
About 3-6 days depending on the complexity
of the topic, 70% of that is research, the
other 30% is made up of sourcing media, filming
and editing.
Sarah and Christopher asked, “Why do you
wear that certain suit in all your videos?”
It might seem like it but I don’t always
wear a suit when I’m off-video.
I do however, like to dress smart whenever
I can.
If someone goes to the effort of putting a
suit on you know they’re fully committed
to the task in hand and it shows they mean
business.
Just like if I worked in an office, when I
“show up for work” every day and make
videos I want to look my absolute best for
you guys.
You’ve gone to the effort of taking ten
minutes out of your day to watch me and that
means a lot to me, so my way of saying thank
you is looking as good as I possibly can for
you.
It’s not about trying to look intelligent
or authoritative, it’s about giving you
the best experience I possibly can when you
watch my videos.
Efren, Ross, Demix, and Eric asked “What
do you do in your spare time?”.
I have two major hobbies, the first is photography.
I’ve been doing amateur photography for
almost ten years now and I even did it professionally
for a short time but the whole business side
of it tainted the enjoyment for me, so now
I do it strictly as a hobby.
My second hobby is cooking.
I love experimenting with food and combining
simple, fresh ingredients.
For me cooking is almost a game, I like taking
an ingredient and seeing what crazy things
I can do to it to really enhance the experience
of eating it.
We eat everyday of our lives so we shouldn’t
make eating a chore, it should be something
we look forward to and get excited about.
Alfred asked “Do you prefer to have facts
around the US or outside the US?”
When it comes to facts I really don’t care
what country it’s from.
I choose facts based on how interesting they
are and nothing more, it’s as simple as
that, if the majority of my facts are based
around the US, that’s only because it’s
an interesting country.
Sure at time I tend to focus my figures and
statistics around America, but that’s only
because the majority of my viewers are American.
That’s also why I use dollars as a representative
currency, even though I’m British, because
dollars are what the majority of my viewers
are use to.
I try my best to make my videos friendly and
accessible to people from every country, the
last thing I want to do is ostracize anyone.
Sheikh asked “Why did you decide to become
a YouTuber?
And where would you be if you werne’t a
YouTuber?”
I already answered why I became a YouTuber
in my first Q&A, I’ll link to that in the
description.
But to answer your other question, what I
would be doing if I weren’t a YouTuber?
It’s highly likely I would be a web developer.
When I was thirteen I taught myself basic
HTML mark-up and CSS.
A few years later and I trained as a graphic
designer in college, but I soon realised I
was more interested with the code working
behind the scenes of a website than making
the frontend look pretty.
So whilst I was in college I taught myself
other programming languages such as Python,
Java and C, mostly out of curiosity to see
what I could do with them.
I’ve always found a certain beauty in code.
A few months after I started YouTube I was
offered a web development job in Manchester
(a city in the north of England) and I had
to make the tough decision between a safe
job in a cushy office or continuing making
fascinating videos, which was what I really
wanted to do.
This was when my channel was still starting
up and it was very uncertain whether anything
would actually become of it.
So I took a risk and chose YouTube.
Luckily I made the right decision and boy
am I glad I did, because this whole experience
has been amazing.
I wouldn’t trade it for anything.
Bomi asked “Do you play video games?
If you do, what’s your favourite game?”
Yes of course, as a teenager I used to play
a lot of video games.
Unfortunately, I don’t play any more, simply
because it’s hard to find the time.
Very, very occasionally I get to kick back
and play but, if I do have spare time, I prefer
to invest it into YouTube because I get a
much bigger kick out of making videos than
shooting aliens.
My all time favourite game is Fallout 3, I
just love the unnerving, dystopian feel to
it.
Maurice asked “Would you rather fight one
horse-sized duck or 100 duck-sized horses?”
I’ve put some thought into this and I think
I’d have to go with one horse-sized duck,
because at least I could always keep it within
my field of vision.
Try doing that with 100 tiny horses, those
sneaky little buggers could be up to anything
behind your back.
Keishla, Genese, Arie, Joris and Lorenzo asked
“What music do you listen to?”
When it comes to music I’m very much stuck
in the past.
I adore 60s and 70s music, specifically the
British rock bands that were so typical of
the era.
The Beatles, The Kinks, Led Zepplin etc.
I’m also a big fan of folk-rock names such
as Bob Dylan, Neil Young, Simon and Garfunkel
and Rodriguez.
Katie asked “What are your favourite books,
and who are your favourite writers?”
It should come as no surprise that one of
my favourite book series is the Hitchhiker’s
Guide series by Douglas Adams.
But I read very little fiction, I love factual
books, I will happily read a book on any topic,
but I particularly like reading Physics books
about stuff such as black holes, the universe
and relativity.
That being said one of my favourite wordsmiths
is actually a fiction author, F. Scott Fitzgerald.
Best known for his novel The Great Gatsby.
The beautiful poetic prose meticulously crafted
into each and every paragraph stayed with
me for years after I read it.
Matthew asked “What’s your favourite drink?”
My favourite drink is coffee, there’s quite
simply nothing better than the smell of freshly
ground coffee beans in the morning.
But being British I also love tea, I know,
so predictable.
In case you were wondering, my favourite alcoholic
beverage is wine.
Liam asked “If you could have a superpower,
what would it be?
And what would you do with it?”
I would love the power to be able to rapidly
flick through a book and absorb all the knowledge
inside in a matter of seconds.
I love learning and that would just be incredible.
Okay I wouldn’t be able to beat up many
villains with that superpower but I would
be able to deploy my superior knowledge to
create computer learning algorithms that predict
were the villains will strike next then cowardly
warn the police.
Yeah, that concept definitely needs some polishing
before it’s made into a super-hero flick.
Andrew asked “When I was a child, what did
I want to be?”
When I was really young I wanted to be a scientist
but as I grew up I saw myself going into either
engineering or computer science, both fields
always interested me and still do.
But as is usually the case, I ended up doing
neither.
I really can’t thank you enough for helping
me to reach such an amazing milestone.
Reaching one million subscribers is by far
the most astonishing think I’ve ever accomplished
in my life, I just really can’t believe
it’s happened to me, so thank you and here’s
to many more years of Thoughty2.